yeah this is a $1,200 burger who you
like that in Vegas everything is pushed
to the extreme and super luxe gourmet
burgers are no exception but are the
hefty price tags worth the height to get
some answers I'm linking up with someone
who's familiar with a big baller
lifestyle Vegas veteran and former Pro
Bowl running back Marshawn Lynch we're
gonna taste test some VIP patties and
hit the lab to create a custom beast
mode burger Marshawn Cheers
welcome to the burger shy hold on hot
I'm thinking red there yeah we gotta
give him some long I said cause he
cheated oh man
we're at the 75th floor Boulevard
penthouse
there's massage tables in the back room
gold everywhere
what is Vegas like as an NFL superstar
oh I think it's like that one TV show
yeah have you ever run up a hotel tap
here to be honest with you Brad I'll do
what they call a ballin on a budget okay
so most of the time my [ __ ] calm okay
you just signed your first NFL contract
you got the first bag and what was your
first baller meal when I got drafted I
was 20 damn my first bowling we all hang
on even lied to you Big Dawg Red Lobster
breath Oh bro I love red I thought I was
doing it I thought I was doing it big
family I ain't gonna lie to you and all
I could think was be cheddar biscuit oh
I thought no let me tell me hey I'm mad
today ass I'll holla chatter I don't
think I'll admit what said of biscuit on
me I'm a simple man fan
yeah hell yeah I'm sorry I get a sense
and it feels like bad Sean Lynch rocking
living the Las Vegas lifestyle is all
about flexing right it's all about how
much money you got how much money you're
gambling what you're wearing
but most importantly how baller your
burgers are all right okay well where
the burger show whistle on yay we could
get whatever we won that's why today
we're gonna try out some maxed out
burgers bro seven hundred twelve hundred
dollars well damn burger number one
super agent even a footstep yes so this
is the 777 burger from the burger brah
sorry right this is a surf and turf
burger what do you think in first things
first look like if some [ __ ] that still
movin on here
it's a $77 burger but if you want it for
seven hundred and seventy seven dollars
you get a Dom P Rosa okay
starts with a toasted corn meal dusted
bun Kobe beef patty its broiled on the
grill topped with goat cheese
caramelized onions pancetta
wah-wah-wah-wah arugula lobster and
drizzled with a hundred-year-old aged
balsamic Finn is dead so what's this
foie gras that's a duck liver it's super
rich its ballin you know what I feel
like it's baller like he just threw a
hundred dollar piece of foie gras I
can't pronounce this year so I damn will
know I shouldn't be eating it it
honestly just tastes like fat that's
what it tastes like
yeah I know okay you give it a get just
a just a little bit yeah I thought it
was a mushroom I don't know what don't
change taste like breath it just tastes
like ricotta it just seems like regular
like let's do see I just got the most
let me see
I feel like Dave Chappelle year y'all I
got dinosaur eggs in my it's on Bali
what are you tasting like I don't taste
the bacon I don't know for sure don't
taste the lobster meaning
there's also that this place you saw me
I know what can I guess a law that this
is the ballers move ever look it even
got my cousin on here we go suave my
personal professional opinion of this
burger mm-hmm
I like everything in this burger bike
everything on its own so I'm not a chef
though right yeah but I don't a some
good ass [ __ ] in my life okay okay but
at the end of the day if I'm gonna pay
seventy seven dollars for for a budget I
want that burger to slap me in the face
but what a [ __ ] apart like I don't know
I mean Doug wah grah forever yeah you
ain't taste that eat your burger number
two oh look at this okay
this is a movie this is a record player
it comes yo if you buy this burger it
comes with a record player yeah this is
a $1,200 burger whoo you like that
that's trouble why you shouldn't it
starts off with a5 Wagyu patty its base
it with truffle Veals you sake rubs
cheddar it comes with a house-made
purple Okinawa potato roll it has MSG
Mayo mushrooms that you can only get in
the fall as a roasted Campari tomato it
comes with a side of poutine white
truffle which they've given us the
Liberty to shave go ahead dig into that
burger I'm gonna get right with you in a
minute hasn't it oh yeah all right I see
what you're doing it will be me to get
get to breaking some [ __ ] you don't be
here so you could get another one this
one looked like it it probably got a
little bit more slop and I got a speaker
on take it
yeah that's what I was taking have you
ever shaved truffle before I have
nothing all right let's do this yeah cuz
I for Sophie knew some [ __ ] with this
Amy yeah you gotta like you gotta like
let it fly on there take it $1,200 to
the
next level where did we just turn it
into a $1400 burger this truffle stink
I lied to my ass cheeks it's day you
trying to have me eat that this this
ain't no blueberry muffin you know that
is purple Okinawa potatoes purple open
now we're past Japan is a heavy
influence on his burger she should be
all right what are you thinking let me
walk you through that here give me some
give me some history some feedback well
I'll take my second bite into it like to
some people that flavor that earthy
flavor is ballin we're talking about the
matsutake mushrooms it has that that
nice woody is that what I'm tasting yeah
and then you have the compare tomatoes
which is probably arguably where the
best tomatoes you could buy that's also
really earthy so that last one had all
that other [ __ ] in it area balsamic oh
yeah but I couldn't taste all the [ __ ]
but yet I bite into this I feel like
I've just been to our old couch cushion
as someone who's been working with these
ingredients for years I understand it
this is like if you were to compare to a
car right this would be like take otezla
and the reason why I say that's guys
it's like it's got the technology and
the way it's made they use high-end
material 85 Wagyu beef and it's like
well thought out
I like your analogy because as you put
it like that that's exactly what it is
because it's not like an old dirty taste
no it's just like an oat but at the same
I had a Tesla C and I got rid of that
getting my 6a stain and let me hop oh
[ __ ] though yeah I mean I feel that the
bread good oh I see where your head's at
now it's time for us to make the B small
burger
cheers to this oh look at this safe it
looks like he just took it out of a bank
a bank vault is there not enough than
that a man this is this is palatial here
we go this is for you my man I know how
you feel about the skittles
pour some skittles you know it don't get
no more baller than that we're in Vegas
that's some players you're right beer me
ah yes yes sir let's go tell nobody you
just can't say no to skittles hello and
welcome to cooking with Alvin and
Marshawn Lynch today we're gonna make
the beast mode burger [ __ ] all right
real quick how long will you leg Sango
what I hear is is that you like chicken
wings true well this burger is inspired
by hot wings
have you ever made hot wing hot sauce no
I haven't well you're in luck I would
have just do hella crystals on it and
call it a day
yeah you're in luck cause that's what
we're doing right now all right
you're not playing oh I'm not playing no
we're doing it for us why not to make
sure it is that real-deal dough how long
yeah taste it please
yep you got you got to do it all right
that's the truth a tablespoon of butter
I don't have it on heat just that just
that the heat from like bringing it to a
simmer and that's all you need to melt
that butter that's it all right you got
the best hot hot wing hot sauce right
there I'm gonna throw these oh you wanna
play no games cook slices of bacon
do you want to what's that salt bay this
pie yeah yeah oh god there's no salt
beta whoo
but I'll call this that also man yeah
thanks prank oh man you know just
picking with a little bit of game
wriggle my main shut off 49 fresh
cracked pepper not a lot how long before
we get there put it on there
whoo tastes good yeah you know I
actually got my home restaurant yeah I
heard about it said Oakland
yeah right what's the call that's Robins
yeah Rob big rock bands Robins Robins
Robins yeah oh there you go yeah nice
I'm making this burger for that place
yeah true if it's good enough they'll be
on your menu I mean regardless if is
good enough or not this story behind
this is enough to have it and I love it
so you see that crust through yeah right
there okay that's what you saw more I
mean want that and since we're using
cheddar my throw it on now I'm gonna go
and pull inaudible oh yeah I'm pulling
on one ball just like amplify the
flavors I'm gonna throw this on here hey
Ted make the best quarterback ha ha ha
mind that rest a little being able to
call an audible in the time so I got
this ciabatta bun you have to always
have a hot bun got some ranch some
sliced jalapeno now we got this yard in
there it's cauliflower onions jalapenos
carrot they're all pickle is a spicy as
bird [ __ ] plates match ha ha chopping
mall check this out this is our call the
beast mode burger guaranteed to be
flames what you thinking a lot to you
family I'm ready if this was gonna hit a
restaurant I'd say it'd probably be
about 25 oh yeah
what do we thinking what are we tasting
[Music]
where we yeah what are we what are we
going for
dog that looks so good he's formulating
he's lady he's formulating man lots of
big dog dad mother [ __ ] is serious
breath a real G [ __ ] yeah honest man $50
for this burger word high compliment
we went from foie gras Lobster
all the [ __ ] to Okinawa purple potatoes
to matsutake mushrooms to the B smoke
flames burger man to the truth bow to
the truth there you have it my boy rush
on we did it we made him a burger we're
gonna sell it look out for it check us
out burger show baby
I've known the wife leg hey that's real
I give up found it
[Music]
what's up everybody it's having Kyle out
of the burger show make sure you turn on
your notifications smash that like
button smash that subscribe button and
thank you for watching